c'est l'heure du second débat de ce sens
public on va prendre le pouls de l'océan
lundi après 15 années de discussion les
pays membres de l'ONU ont adopté un
traité de protection de la haute mer
avant d'en débattre on vous explique ce
que seront ces aires marines protégées
dans les eaux internationales avec
Quentin calmer il aura fallu 15 ans de
négocier à Sion donc quatre années
formelles pour trouver cet accord lundi
les États membres de l'ONU ont adopté le
premier traité international de
protection de la haute mer un moment
historique selon le secrétaire général
des Nations unies notre Océan est menacé
mais le traité sur la haute mer sur la
protection de la diversité donne à
l'océan une chance de se battre cette
réalisation historique est un exemple de
menace mondial auquel répond une action
mondiale principale mesure du texte qui
doit maintenant être ratifiée par au
moins 60 pays il fixe un objectif de
protection de 30% des océans à l'horizon
de 2030 un premier pas dans l'action
pour protéger la biodiversité de nos
océans dans un contexte de fortes
pressions sur cette écosystème parmi les
plus importantes la pollution plastique
un enjeu au cœur d'un autre sommet de la
communauté internationale à l'UNESCO à
Paris début juin
nous constatons que d'ici 2050 il y aura
plus de déchets plastiques que de
poissons dans les océans nous devons
donc prendre des mesures internationales
pour résoudre ce problème les actions
locales ne suffiront pas c'est pourquoi
nous avons besoin d'une interdiction
internationale et ou plutôt sera nul
l'océan également sous la pression du
réchauffement continue de la température
de l'eau le nuit évoque depuis plusieurs
semaines le risque de voir se reproduire
cet été le phénomène El ninho un courant
d'eau chaude qui traverse le Pacifique à
la clé des craintes pour l'ensemble de
la planète
les trois dernières années ont été des
années la ninia avec un impact de
refroidissement la dernière année d'El
ninho a été 2016 lorsque nous avons
battu pour la dernière fois le record de
chaleur
il est très probable que nous
atteindrons à nouveau à un niveau record
au cours des cinq prochaines années ce
phénomène risque donc d'accentuer les
fortes chaleurs des prochains mois en
plus d'impacter la capacité de nos
océans à capter le CO2
comment protéger l'océan pourquoi
joue-t-il un rôle majeur dans la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique en en
débat avec Jean-Louis Étienne bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes explorateur et
médecin Marina Lévy bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes
océanographe directrice de recherche au
CNRS et directrice adjointe du
département
océan climat et ressources de l'Institut
de Recherche pour le Développement
Frédéric lemanach bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi directeur scientifique de
l'association de défense des océans
Bloom évidemment Mathieu croissanto est
resté à mes côtés Jean-Louis Étienne
vous préparez une une expédition
scientifique du courant circum polaire
austral avec un navire vertical le polar
pod vous expliquerez tout ça dans un
instant on prendra le temps d'en parler
parce que c'est c'est passionnant mais
je commence quand même avec cet accord
historique qui a été signé à l'ONU
est-ce que vous y voyez un vrai progrès
est-ce que vous dites attention c'est un
peu un accord en trompe l'oeil comment
vous réagissez c'est un progrès de la
mesure où il existe
pas exister ça sera encore pire
donc effectivement c'est toujours des
bases le le problème il est énorme vous
voyez ce que je veux dire donc
toutes les bons fois qui sont faits
effectivement sont dans le bon sens ça
c'est mon point de vue effectivement on
voit bien que ces réunions généralistes
à quelques-unes quoi ce sont des
essentiellement des diplomates qui sont
là souvent les diplomates ils arrivent
en ils ont ils ont la consigne dire ils
ne fous pendant la merde vous voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est un peu ça
c'est-à-dire que le diplomate il va
faire un minima de manière à ce qu'il
puisse rentrer chez lui à la maison
tranquille et donc ce sont des
phénomènes effectivement qui sont
contre-productifs souvent ça dépend des
pays bien sûr et puis effectivement
maintenant on va attendre la
ratification des des pays et c'est une
vraie question un vrai débat l'objectif
mais de protéger 30% des océans d'ici
2030 est-ce que ça vous semble réalise
soit qu'aujourd'hui on en est à peine à
1% c'est ça dans des zones dites
protégées oui alors après il y a
plusieurs questions qui se posent par
rapport à ces protections
la première c'est ce qu'on est capable
de vérifier que les zones sont
effectivement protégées comment faire
pour assurer vérifier simplement que les
zones ne sont tout de même pas
exploitées ça c'est la première question
et c'est pas du tout évident parce que
30% c'est une surface énorme vous savez
que les océans couvrent 70% de la
planète et puis la deuxième question
c'est quel est le niveau de protection
on s'est rendu compte que non seulement
il fallait protéger mais qu'il fallait
des niveaux de protection assez élevés
pour que les écosystèmes qui ont été
dégradés puissent se régénérer et ça
également ce sont vraiment des questions
de fond qui qui sont clés et on a mesuré
que il fallait des niveaux de protection
très élevés pour avoir des régénérations
les plus efficaces possibles et ça
marche très bien c'est à dire que en un
ou deux ans on arrive à régénérer un
écosystème si on protège parfaitement la
vie alors ça j'espère qu'on aura le
temps de le réexpliquer un peu plus en
détail mais je continue mon premier tour
de table Frédéric Le malac c'est vrai
que il y a il y a deux lectures ou deux
analyses de cet accord international on
peut se dire enfin enfin il y a un
accord mondial à l'ONU on va définir des
zones protégées les faire grandir 30% de
l'océan bon très bien et puis ensuite on
peut aussi se dire c'est quoi une zone
protégée et aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elles
sont vraiment protégées de la surpêche
des extractions minières etc etc
qu'est-ce que vous dites alors très
bonne question effectivement dans le
reportage on parle de pollution
plastique qui n'est pas du tout
considéré par les scientifiques de
l'IPBS donc qui est l'équivalent du GIEC
pour la biodiversité comme la menace
numéro 1 en fait la menace numéro 1
c'est vraiment la pêche industrielle la
surpêche et donc on voit très bien dans
les eaux françaises par exemple que on a
un objectif de 30% aussi dans les eaux
nationales pas uniquement en haute mer
et on n'est pas du tout sur cet objectif
là donc le président Macron se targue
d'avoir rempli cet objectif là au niveau
international et pourtant quand on
regarde la protection réelle on est
effectivement à autour de 1% 2%
est-ce que c'est une forme de course
contre-la-montre c'est-à-dire est-ce
qu'il faut
urgemment interdire ces techniques de
pêche pour pour laisser le temps à
l'océan de se régénérer vous voyez ce
que je veux dire alors ce qu'il y a ce
qu'il faut traquer ce qui reçoivent
cette pêche à terre c'est la seule façon
qu'on a de la réguler par exemple il y a
il y a un énorme bateau chinois pour le
citer c'est un énorme congélateur qui
est au large de l'Afrique au large de
Pointe-Noire par exemple un petit peu
plus loin ben ils ont contracté avec les
pêcheurs locaux et qui vont vendre leurs
pêcheurs en deux one en dehors de la
zone des 12 nautiques et donc le marché
totalement ouvert et donc c'est ces
pêcheurs africains préfèrent aller
vendre au bateau chinois congélateur en
mer que de manger j'étais un pointe noir
dit nous on mange maintenant du poisson
congelé qui vient du Brésil donc voyez
il y a l'absurdité oui il faut se rendre
compte qu'effectivement c'est difficile
de traquer les bateaux parce que ceux
qui veulent faire de la surpêche souvent
il coupe une façon d'être pour bien
comprendre ce bateau chinois il est dans
ses eaux internationales dont on dont on
parle avec la
correctation d'accord mais donc je
reviens vers vous avec le malaxe ça veut
dire que si dans un monde idéal ça
prendra peut-être des années voir des
décennies mais bon espérons que ça aille
plus vite que prévu les États les états
de l'ONU ratifient cet accord dans ton
dont on parle ce type de comportement ne
pourrait plus avoir lieu pas vraiment
parce qu'en fait dans l'accord sur la
haute mer de l'ONU la pêche n'est pas
intégrée parce qu'en fait là il existe
déjà un accord de fin un traité on Usain
sur la réglementation de la pêche c'est
en accord de 1995 sur les espèces de
poissons les populations qu'on appelle
chevauchante et migratrice par exemple
les tons et donc comme il y a déjà un
traité onusien sur la pêche industrielle
en haute mer c'est exclu de ce traité là
de même que on a aussi les activités
minières qui sont exclues et donc en
fait
le droit au Muséum juste une remarque et
on essaye de faire une ère marine
protégée autour de l'Antarctique on est
loin des pays habités a pratiquement
tout le monde est d'accord sauf les
Russes et les Chinois et donc ça fait
longtemps que la caméra essaie de mettre
une aire marine protégée dans ce secteur
autour de l'Antarctique et qu'il n'y
arrive pas il suffit que deux pays qui
disent NON et ça ne se fait pas alors
que c'est Marine protéger ce sont des
maternités extraordinaires si vous
voulez toutes les espèces viennent se
reproduire tranquillement là
alors on va revenir à toutes ces
questions mais je voudrais qu'on fasse
un stop tout de suite dans ce débat
Marina Lévy pour expliquer on attitré
climat l'enjeu vital des océans alors on
pourrait d'abord dire que normalement si
on est très très précis on dit un océan
c'est-à-dire c'est ça il y a pas
désocéans il y en a un seul on dit on
dit un océan parce que tous les océans
sont interconnectés c'est vraiment une
masse d'eau c'est un fluide qui entoure
la planète et tout c'est comme un les
courants ils peuvent aller d'un endroit
et d'ailleurs ils vont d'un endroit à
l'autre de l'océan tout est relié dans
les océans pourquoi il est vital
pourquoi il nous protège notamment du
réchauffement climatique c'est quoi le
rôle de l'océan expliquez-nous ça alors
l'océan ça joue un rôle très important
dans le système climatique parce que ça
a une capacité calorifique très
importante alors qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ce que ça veut dire c'est que on
sait que voilà on subit tout le monde
sait qu'on subit le réchauffement
climatique en ce moment et bien 90% de
la chaleur excédentaire donc la chaleur
liée à nos activités elle est dans les
océans
ça veut dire que ce que en fait ce que
ça veut dire c'est qu'on ne subit que
10% en fait du réchauffement climatique
sur terre et c'est 90% ils ont conduit à
une augmentation des températures des
océans mais les océans ils nous ont
aussi protégé pour d'autres raisons au
niveau physique j'entends c'est qu'ils
ont absorbé une partie des gaz à effet
de serre donc le CO2 qui est responsable
à l'origine du réchauffement climatique
un quart de nos émissions a été absorbée
par les océans et ça ça a conduit à une
augmentation de l'acidité des océans et
puis alors il y a d'autres effets de
protection des océans qui nous protègent
des effets du changement climatique par
exemple les vagues les tempêtes sont on
les côtes nos cotes sont protégées de
manière naturelle par des systèmes de
mangrove par des algues qui vont faire
des barrières naturelles par exemple
donc vraiment l'océan agit vraiment
comme un comme un protecteur Mathieu
l'enjeu cette question des océans ou de
l'océan c'est c'est un enjeu politique
est-ce que c'est vraiment nouveau ça
j'avais envie de
parodie Renaud c'est pas l'homme
politique qui prend la mer c'est la mère
qui prend l'homme politique en fait
c'est c'est pas de nouveau mais c'est
depuis 2017 quand même que la question
de l'avenir de nos océans et de la mer a
fait ruption dans le débat public
au-delà de la sphère écolo montant parce
que la sphère écologiste on a quand même
beaucoup parlé on pourrait tout à fait
honnête le premier secrétaire la marine
ça date pas d'hier mais d'avant-hier
c'était en 1669 il s'appelait Colbert
mais à l'époque l'essentiel ça
fonctionne était consacré à la marine
royale autrement dit la manière
militaire et ça va d'ailleurs rester
comme ça à peu près jusqu'au milieu du
20e siècle le Ministre en charge vont
avoir progressivement
vont se voir adjoint de la marine
marchande et puis en 58 le ministère de
la mer il est supprimé la composante
militaire va au ministère la défense et
la composante marine marchande va au
ministère des Transports et depuis c'est
assez intermittent François Mitterrand
rétablit le poste mais avec un rendent
secrétaire d'État qui disparaît sous la
cohabitation d'Edward Balladur et dans
le premier septennat de Jacques Chirac
ça disparaît aussi dans les trois
premières années du du quinquennat
Sarkozy il faudra attendre des
présidents qui ont plutôt la main
généreuse en termes de portefeuille
ministériel on s'affrançois Hollande
mais surtout Emmanuel Macron pour voir
resurgir des ministres ou des
secrétaires d'État entièrement dédiés la
mer évidemment les partis politiques se
sont eux aussi en parler de la question
oui alors je parlais des écolos grande
défenseur de la biodiversité et qui ont
fait notamment leurs armes politiques au
moment des marées noires qu'on frappé on
se souvient la fin des années 70 ou les
années 80 mais jusqu'à l'Erica dans les
années 90 mais il faisait il faut quand
même reconnaître que c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon version 2017 qui a fait de
l'or bleu comme il le dit une nouvelle
frontière au même titre que l'espace est
en gros pour lui c'est le moteur du
nouvel économie c'est lui quand même qui
a mis ce débat là et j'allais dire en
2017 ça faisait un peu rigoler tout le
monde se dit mais qu'est-ce qui lui
prend donc lui Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
pense à l'époque que ça peut générer 300
000 emplois 70 milliards d'euros à la
clé je disais sa surpris tout le monde
mais depuis le patron de la France
insoumise non des Maures pas alors il
est très axé lui sur le développement
des énergies marines mais son programme
s'est étoffé avec le temps de mesure sur
la biodiversité ou encore la lutte
contre les pesticides fantastique on en
a parlé et ça même été le thème je sais
pas si vous souvenez pour la campagne
présidentielle vous avez fait un grand
meeting oui merci et olfactif à Nantes
voilà on est au visuellement
c'était assez impressionnant du côté de
l'exécutif mais du côté de l'exécutif
Emmanuel Macron lui aussi a fini par se
saisir du sujet donc en 2021 il annonce
qu'il y aura un sommaire 2022 le One
Ocean Summit qu'il convoque à Brest où
il annonce une série de mesures et de
propositions pour lutter contre la
pollution liée au fret maritime contre
les plastiques il prône aussi ce fameux
traité qu'on voit arriver aujourd'hui
pour protéger 30% de l'espace océanique
le 7 novembre dernier il surprend
jusqu'aux associations écologistes il
est à la COP 27 en Égypte et là il se
prononce pour l'interdiction de
l'exploitation des fonds marins ce qui
surprend tout le monde tout le monde
attendra un peu comment comment ça va se
jouer et puis au début du mois de juin
tout récemment il le redit sa volonté de
faire de 2025 l'année des océans il
rappelle qu'on est la deuxième puissance
maritime grâce à nos outre et en gros il
poursuivre et à prendre le leadership
sur ce sur ce dossier
pourquoi pas mais à condition en tout
cas que ça reste pas comme j'allais dire
une bouteille à mer voilà que ce soit
des actes un vrai ami à condition que
les actes suivent Frédéric Le Malaga
vous êtes assez critique sur le bilan
des Macron pourquoi
parce que à part le ce totem d'immunité
dont vous avez parlé sur le moratoire
sur l'exploitation minière qui est
effectivement une très bonne chose qui a
été applaudi au niveau mondial c'était
demandé par les ONG par les
scientifiques par la société civile donc
tout le monde est d'accord pour ça
c'était de demander de longue date mais
à part cette annonce là qui est suivie
dans les faits en fait c'est plutôt des
discours et donc typiquement à Brest la
dernière monsieur Macron a annoncé que
la France avait déjà protégé 30% de ses
eaux alors que c'est pas du tout vrai
des chercheurs du CNRS le montrent
Joachim Claudette par exemple qui
travaille là-dessus très précisément
quantifier le niveau de protection en
France et on est à quelques pour cent
des micro %. et c'est comme je disais
tout à l'heure principalement dans les
eaux des arts australes et donc on a
vous avez parlé du secrétaire d'État à
la mer monsieur Berville qui lui a
annoncé au Sénat qu'il était fermement
que la France était fermement opposée à
l'interdiction du chef étage de fond
dans les aires marines protégées et donc
d'un côté on a un président qui dit on
est champion du monde on a 30% de
protection et en fait quand on regarde
on protège pas puisqu'on détruit donc on
a on a quelque chose qui on a des
paroles et des actes qui sont pas du
tout alignés et nous c'est ça qu'on
critique bien évidemment nous on regarde
pas les discours on regarde les actes il
y a toujours un argument qui qui est
opposé au disco commissaire c'est
l'argument on va dire économique combien
de personnes en France vivent de cette
économie de la pêche est-ce qu'on les
mettrait en danger en interdisant ce
type de ce type de de chalut alors non
puisque en fait toutes les études
scientifiques et les rares endroits au
monde où on a interdit ces pratiques là
en fait on voit que on a une
régénération des écosystèmes marins on a
des pêcheurs qui pêchent mieux et qui
valorisent mieux les produits de leur
pêche donc qui gagnent plus d'argent ou
par exemple alors par exemple au
Royaume-Uni on a on a on commence à
avoir vraiment des zones de protection
strictes mais par exemple je sais pas
aussi à Madagascar on travaille avec des
ONG parlons bluevinceurs ce qui a mis en
place des air marines protégées avec les
communautés côtières et donc les on a
très bien vu cet quantifié les salaires
des pêcheurs ont explosé quand ils ont
commencé à protéger certaines zones à ne
plus y pêcher ou à ne plus y pêcher
pendant un certain temps ne dites
l'argument social il tient pas Maria
vous l'avez dit rapidement tout à
l'heure si on laisse tranquille l'océan
il se régénère en combien de temps les
herbiers la possible et les coraux etc
etc j'ai dit oui en un ou deux ans les
choses arrivent à se régénérer mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on parle d'un
deuxième sujet peut-être qui est une
autre menace sur les océans qui est
l'effet du changement climatique parce
que on a parlé de la surpêche on a parlé
des problèmes de pêche on parler des
problèmes de pollution et si on réglait
les problèmes de pêche et de pollution
on ne réglerait pas encore la santé des
océans qui c'est lié à ce que vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire comme
l'océan nous protège en absorbant du CO2
et du réchauffement il en est victime
aussi quoi c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer donc les os se réchauffent
donc les os elles sont de plus en plus
chaudes et ça c'est des conséquences en
cascade sur les habitats des écosystèmes
les eaux plus chaudes ce que ça veut
dire les autres surfaces quand elles
sont plus chaudes ça veut dire qu'elles
peuvent moins se mélanger avec les
autres fonds
stratification c'est ça il y a une
histoire de stratification c'est plus
stratifié quand c'est plus stratifié
l'océan quand il est plus chaud il peut
absorber moins d'oxygène donc il est
moins oxygène entre les autres surfaces
et les mélanges ça veut dire qu'on va
moins fertiliser les océans et puis il y
a plus de CO2 il va devenir plus acide
et puis il va y avoir plus de vagues de
chaleur on en a vu l'année dernière en
Méditerranée il y a une vague de chaleur
épouvantable en ce moment même en
Atlantique donc si vous voulez
si l'océan c'était un être humain et
qu'il arrivait aux urgences en lui
dirait ben là vous avez un peu de fièvre
vous avez des grosses poussées de fièvre
de plus en plus fréquentes vous avez
votre rythme cardiaque qui ralentit et
votre taux d'oxygène qui descend et les
poissons ils habitent là-dedans et donc
on voit déjà des conséquences sur les
poissons au Texas la semaine dernière il
y a eu la mort de milliers de poissons
qui ont été retrouvés sur les plages et
ça c'est lié au manque d'oxygène on a
des méduses qui arrivent en Bretagne
avec une perturbation de tous tous les
équilibres et ça c'est lié au
réchauffement des eaux on a vraiment des
perturbations intenses qui vont arriver
et dont on ne voit que le commencement
Jean-Louis Étienne je voudrais que vous
nous parliez de polar pod donc cette
mission scientifique c'est quoi
l'objectif est-ce que ça ça votre
objectif rejoint finalement les les
questions qu'on est en train de se poser
l'objectif une compréhension de l'océan
Austral qui est l'océan qui est autour
de l'Antarctique on parle de
l'hémisphère sud austral Australie cette
immense océan qui fait le tour de
Antarctique les marins appellent les 50e
hurlants oui ce sont des hommes
préventés c'est un immense océan qui est
qui serait le principal puis de carbone
océanique de la planète donc on est au
cœur de notre de Notre-Dame oui et
toutes les publications sur cette océan
se termine toujours par la même phrase
on a besoin de mesurer une situation
on aurait besoin de séjourner sur cet
océan les campagnes se font
essentiellement l'été c'est loin
difficile l'accès et c'est ce que vous
allez faire et donc quel type de
vaisseau pour séjourner sur les 50e
hurlant dans des bonnes conditions de
sécurité de confort et dans la seule
façon d'échapper à la surface là où le
vent et la mer se rencontrent ça fait
c'est les conflits il faut avoir le
navire vertical qui descend profond on
va voir on va voir quelques images ce
sont évidemment des images de de 3D des
images de synthèse qui ont été créées
parce que pour leur pote il est pas
encore construit mais allez-y continue
la description donc il fait 75 mètres de
tyrando donc on est pris dans des eaux
profondes beaucoup plus stables et à la
surface on devine il y a un treillis
c'est à dire et la mère passe à travers
on n'est pas percuté comme un bateau
donc il offre cette capacité à séjourner
sur cet océan des bonnes conditions de
sécurité de confort donc c'est un navire
donc qui est autonome le moteur c'est le
courant l'énergie c'est le vent et dans
les zones très très ventées et donc
cette autonomie va nous permettre de
séjourner les chercheurs nous ont
demandé de faire deux fois le tour on
sait pas quelle vitesse ça va se faire
on pense trois années qu'il faut pour
faire de Tours et c'est porté par le
courant c'est ça exactement c'est le
courant qui nous entraîne et comme il y
a du vent l'électricité c'est le vent et
donc un échange atmosphère aux séances
ça c'est l'axe 1 puis c'est un vaisseau
qui n'a pas de moteur pas de groupe
électrogène il est autonome on va mettre
des hydrophones des micro sous l'eau et
par acoustique passive on va faire un
inventaire de la faune parce qu'on
connaît la signature sonore de toutes
les espèces et puis troisième axe entre
autres et on va faire des prélèvements
et regarder qu'est-ce qu'on trouve dans
des eaux si distales par rapport à nos
pays vous attendez avec impatience les
résultats de cette expédition ça vous
servira à la peut-être à prendre les
bonnes décisions
qui a une question importante dans les
océans c'est que les océans quelque part
c'est invisible on ne voit que une masse
d'eau bleue et sous cette invisibilité
se cache une énorme diversité c'est à
dire que c'est aussi varié que sur terre
il y a des régimes des articles dans les
océans il y a des régimes qui sont très
productifs etc et donc on a besoin de
sciences on a besoin de technologie pour
aller voir ce qui se passe et comment ça
varie et c'est 20 dernières années il y
a eu des développements technologiques
extraordinaires qui ont permis de faire
des des progrès incroyables les
satellites qui permettent d'observer les
océans il y a des robots autonomes il y
a des milliers de petits robots qui vont
sonder les océans chaque jour et donc on
a besoin de ces développements
technologiques pour aller plus loin et
pour mieux comprendre ce qu'on ne voit
pas c'est le principal puis de carbone
océanique vous comprenez il absorbe il
absorbe réa lui seul la moitié
du CO2 absorbé par l'ensemble de l'océan
mondial parce que c'est un océan agité
donc il y a des vagues ça emprisonnent
de l'air et comme le CO2 silicium
beaucoup plus dans les eaux froides que
dans les eaux tempérés et cette immense
surface en fait le principal pi de
carbone et un détail c'est que 6
l'océans se réchauffe déjà de quelques
dixièmes c'est océan va perdre sa
capacité à recapurer le Gasquet
entre 8 et 2 degrés proche de zéro
certaines fois on est quand même assez
loin de l'Antarctique on n'est jamais
dans la glace si vous voulez on est à
une latitude qui est 55 Sud qui est un
peu correspond dans notre hémisphère à
l'Écosse si tout va bien il est mis à
l'eau à quel moment ce polar on espère
juin 2025 ça c'est le choix ça fait ça
fait 12 ans que je travaille dessus
c'est un c'est un acharnement et il y a
des relèves d'équipage qui se feront
tous les deux mois personne va rester 3
ans avec un bateau que j'ai baptisé
persévérant oui on a vu l'image alors
lui il il a été baptisé ce bateau la
semaine dernière
on comprend bien pourquoi vous l'avez
cette goalée de vous l'avez baptisé de
ce nom persévérance et résister à
l'attentation de la bandeau vous voyez
donc c'est ce qui fait que on y arrive
il est en train d'y arriver avec
Ifremer le CNRS tout un comité
scientifique et avec Marie il vous
manque un peu de financement mais tout
le temps ça c'est ça c'est la base les
terres finances la construction
l'investissement c'est l'état
l'exploitation c'est moi et donc je
passe mon temps effectivement à chercher
de l'argent mais ça tous les chercheurs
passent leur temps à faire ça alors vous
nous disiez effectivement que l'une des
difficultés c'était que
cette invisibilité on va revenir à ces
questions de pollution même si vous avez
dit que c'était peut-être pas le plus
important on va parler de pollution
plastique quand même dans ce débat on
fait un débat sur l'océan on peut pas ne
pas parler évidemment de de la pollution
plastique je vous propose d'entendre un
témoignage celui de la navigatrice Maud
Fontenoy qui est également ambassadrice
pour l'éducation à la mer auprès du
ministère de l'Éducation
dit l'océan poubelle des activités
humaines on l'écoute
sur les océans que sur la terre ferme
et quand j'ai eu un frigo entre deux
eaux au large de l'Antarctique pendant
mon tour du monde ou quand j'ai ramé
dans le Pacifique et que j'ai croisé une
nappe d'hydrocarbures c'est vrai qu'on
se dit quand même qu'il y a vraiment un
problème et que finalement ce sont que
les stigmates de nos actions sur terre
80-90% de la pollution marine elle vient
d'abord de la terre donc c'est nos
activités qui ont un impact sur nos
océans Frédéric lemanac il y a la
pollution visible dont dont on parle
d'un mot de Fontenoy et puis il y a la
pollution invisible les microplastiques
peut-être que vous pouvez nous expliquer
de quoi on parle on et alors vous me
dites c'est peut-être pas le plus
dangereux mais quand même de de quoi on
parle avec le plastique alors c'est pas
non plus le sujet d'expertise de
l'association Bloom alors nous on est
vraiment sur les questions de pêche mais
les microplastiques pour faire très
simple en fait c'est des plastiques du
plastique qui utilisaient sur terre qui
est dégradé se dégrade dans l'eau c'est
ça l'action des UV par l'action du sel
de l'eau etc et donc on a du plastique
qui est de plus en plus fragmenté à tel
point que les les animaux marins peuvent
l'ingérer et donc on retrouve du
plastique maintenant dans le kril les
poissons etc puisque en fait il est
dégradé de manière tellement fine qu'il
est ingéré il se retrouve dans les
tissus et donc on a notre pollution qui
se retrouve dans ce qu'on consomme
maintenant Jean-Louis Étienne je
rappelle vous êtes médecin donc ça veut
dire nous on est au bout de la chaîne
alimentaire c'est-à-dire que on en
retrouve dans nos organismes
comme tu dis les microplastiques sont
des petits îlots microscopiques sur
lequel se développe le phytoplancton et
donc la crevette ou le cri il va manger
ses petites choses là le copier pod la
crevette de manger puis le poisson et
puis nous et puis nous c'est comme ça
que ça rentre effectivement dans le
réseau alimentaire et est-ce que ça
participe oui ou non je ne sais pas j'ai
pas la réponse fixe elle est fixe dans
le développement le phytoplancton vous
pourrez en parler mieux que moi tous les
pas que les microplastiques les organes
colorés les pesticides les métaux lourds
tout ça se fixe effectivement dans ces
dans cette dans cette croissance du
phytoplancton c'est des comme vous
disiez à l'échelle microscopique et
c'est comme ça que ça rentre ça peut y
avoir des bactéries et des virus aussi
qui se développent sur sur ces micro
plastiques on les voit au microscope
quand on prend une goutte d'eau on
regarde on voit ces microplastes mais
est-ce que c'est micro plastique
participe au dérèglement général de
l'océan au-delà de cette chaîne
alimentaire dont on a parlé etc etc
est-ce que dans la dans l'équation du du
dérèglement océanique ça y est parti ou
pas d'ailleurs je dirais que ça
participe essentiellement par les sujets
dont on a déjà abordé c'est à dire le
fait que on va les ingérer et que et que
les tout le monde les ingère ça
participe pas directement des règlements
climatiques par exemple c'est une autre
action négative de l'homme sur
l'environnement ce qu'il faut voir c'est
que c'est la somme de ses actions qui
infinie fait une situation
catastrophique face à cette pollution
plastique de l'océan tient je vous
propose un autre témoignage c'est du
porte-parole de l'association surf rider
fondation on va le dire en anglais il en
sait un appel aux industriels c'était
lors d'une opération de nettoyage des
des plages on est à Pornic
Loire-Atlantique
distributeur les producteurs de produits
arrêtés d'utiliser du plastique passons
sur de l'achat en vrac passons sur une
véritable économie circulaire revenons à
la consigne passons sur des systèmes qui
évitent qu'on utilise autant de
plastique ce qui fera que on
occasionnera moins de perte l'océan
aujourd'hui est jonché de plastique on
estime comme vous le savez certainement
un chiffre qui a beaucoup été dit que
d'ici 2050 il y aura plus de plastique
que de poissons dans l'océan il est
urgent de se déplastifier alors cette
affirmation effectivement ça fait des
années que je l'entends d'ici 2050 si
rien n'est fait il y aura plus de
plastique que de poissons dans l'océan
elle sort d'où
elle est basée
par contre ce que je sais c'est qu'il y
a plein de sources de plastique
différentes et par exemple ces micro
plastiques il y a une source qui est
très importante c'est les fibres de nos
vêtements et qui vont passer dans l'eau
des machines à laver et en fait il y a
une grande grande partie c'est pas c'est
pas assez plastique d'emballage mais
c'est voilà c'est simplement les
vêtements se comporte et donc
effectivement 80 voire 90% de ces
plastiques viennent de l'activité
humaine de la terre enfin voilà c'est
une ville c'est une évidence de vie et
sur idiote mais ça disparaîtra pas tout
seul il y a pas de moyens que comme un
quelque chose peut se dégrader sur
l'aspirateur disparaît pas mais on sait
même pas où il est c'est à dire que on
n'est pas on sait combien on en met et
dans l'océan on a un plastique manquant
si vous voulez on n'arrive pas à mesurer
toute la quantité de plastique qu'on a
mis dans les océans allez-y Jean-Louis
j'ai fait une expédition à Clipperton
Clipperton c'est un bout deal français
tout petit tout petit dans le Pacifique
personne n'y habite vous arrivez sur
Clipperton vous marchez sur le plastique
c'est incroyable c'est une surprise
totale parce qu'il y a un courant qui
amène tout ça vous avez deux toux
l'évoquer notre Fontenoy des des frigos
vous avez des tongs jamais la paire vous
avez des des choses alors ce qui est
drôle c'est que la faune locale les
oiseaux ont commencé s'habituer parce
qu'ils pondent sur le sol et ils se font
des espèces de petits nid avec des bouts
de plastique et trop il y a une
évolution de écosystèmes mais c'est là
qu'on se rend compte de tout ce qui est
tout ce que l'on met l'envoie la mer
donc ça c'est de l'irrespect total c'est
on a une action là-dessus c'est de le
coincer en amont ça peut le faire oui de
moi de moi en produire de moins
consommer de le recycler etc et surtout
ne pas l'envoyer partout alors je
voudrais qu'on revienne au rôle de de
l'océan et notamment de la poussillonner
on parlait de de l'herbe des mers qui
disparaît dans certaines zones menacées
notamment par la pollution et la pêche
illégale je vous propose d'écouter un
pêcheur tunisien conscient du danger
eux j'ai bien conscience que si la
posidonie disparaît ça affectera notre
approvisionnement en poissons et
j'aimerais faire quelque chose pour ça
car il s'agit de mon gagne pas ainsi que
celui de mes enfants et de mes
petits-enfants
nous ne l'avons pas protégé pas
seulement nous les pêcheurs mais l'état
non plus nous on est bien obligé de
pêcher pour nourrir nos enfants
Jean-Louis Étienne la possédonie c'est
une herbe marine tout simplement c'est
quoi un producteur d'oxygène un peu de
carbone ça joue quel rôle qui veut
répondre peut-être Marina Lili la
possibilité ce sont des algues qu'on
trouve près des côtes effectivement et
ce sont des habitats pour les poissons
surtout c'est surtout ça le rôle que ça
joue et donc ça va accueillir une énorme
biodiversité
et et si les températures augmentent les
poissons ils peuvent aller migrer vers
des températures plus clémentes mais les
algues tout à l'heure il y a des espèces
qui qui vont dans des zones de la
planète où elles étaient pas habituelles
mais ça peut aussi détruire les algues
qui sont fixés dans le sol comme les
petits donies et les tuer et c'est ce
qu'on voit par exemple avec les
phénomènes alors c'est pas des possibles
mais les blanchiment des coraux qui se
dégradent et qui sont aussi des habitats
de biodiversité extraordinaire et qui
avec l'augmentation des températures
meurent il y a aussi ce qu'on appelle
les déserts océaniques alors ça veut
dire quoi c'est quoi un désert océanique
et d'où ça vient alors ça ça vient de du
sens des vents qui fait qu'en fait tous
les nutriments les engrais des océans
sont dans ces régions là très profondes
et c'est dans les dans les Gires ce
qu'on appelle les Gires subtropicales
donc ça les régions subtropicales des
océans donc il y a très peu
d'enrichissement en nutritifs ce qui
fait qu'il y a très peu de phytoplancton
et donc vraiment il y a des contrastes
en production de biomasse vivante entre
ces Gires qui sont très pauvres qui sont
des vrais déserts et puis des régions
comme dans l'Atlantique Nord où on a des
vrais forêts et ça ça se voit pas c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure il
faut vraiment être océanographe aller
voir les choses dans l'eau à les
regarder avec un microscope
éventuellement même aller regarder avec
un satellite ça se voit très bien avec
des satellites qui mesure la couleur de
l'eau et la couleur de l'eau ça vous dit
combien être chlorophylle dans l'eau et
dans ces déserts il y a très peu de
chlorophylle donc l'eau elle apparaît
comme très bleu très transparente et ça
se voit depuis l'espace c'est
merveilleux
mais il y a pas de vie non mais c'est
naturel alors par contre ce qui est pas
naturel et ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que l'étendue de ces désert augmente et
on a une désertification en fait des
océans à cause du réchauffement à cause
du réchauffement à cause de cette
augmentation de stratification dont on
parlait tout à l'heure plus difficile de
transfert entre les gens de surfaces et
des certifications qu'on observe très
nettement depuis 20 ans
qui monte et qui amène de la substance
nutritive et là il y a une pêche
extraordinaire comme par exemple au
Pérou
au large de la des côtes africaines nord
par exemple vous avez ces courants qui
remontent de la nourriture il fallait
que le malaxe de de positiver un peu
est-ce qu'il y a des exemples ouais ce
qui est pas facile hein mais
Matthieu vous a un peu posé la question
tout à l'heure mais est-ce qu'il y a des
des exemples de régénération
rapide réussie avec un volontarisme
aussi de de l'état des pouvoirs publics
c'est sûr qu'il faut de toute façon de
la volonté politique c'est pas les
citoyens chacun de leur côté qui vont
réussir à faire bouger ces lignes-là
enfin on en parlait tout à l'heure on
est tout à fait d'accord même si on
arrivait à régler certains problèmes de
toute façon on a le changement
climatique qui nous arrive dans la
figure on est déjà en plein dedans
l'Atlantique n'a jamais été aussi chaud
qu'actuellement on a un phénomène Nino
qui arrive qui est d'une ampleur sans
précédent on a
que le Royaume-Uni a décidé de mettre en
place des air marines qui sont
réellement protégées et on voit déjà que
dans les zones où on chalutait à
l'époque et donc on avait des fonds
sabot vaseux qui étaient tout plat
c'était des terrains de football avec
aucune diversité en fait simplement en
l'espace d'un an ou deux ans on a déjà
des éponges des coraux froids des vers
qui viennent qui viennent se mettre là
et donc on a de nouveau très rapidement
une structuration en trois dimensions
des écosystèmes marins avec des poissons
qui vont venir des petits poissons des
gros poissons et donc on a vraiment en
l'espace de quelques années on passe
d'un gazon comme un jardin si vous
laissez votre gazon à l'abandon pendant
plusieurs années enfin vous allez avoir
des fleurs des papillons des insectes
dans tous les sens au bout de quelques
années pour les fonds marins c'est
exactement pareil et donc ça c'est un
signal qui est extrêmement positif on
voit très bien que quand on laisse la
nature faire quand on la laisse
tranquille et qu'on arrête de la
détruire en l'espace de quelques années
on arrive à régénérer des écosystèmes
marins qui sont qui sont exceptionnels
il y a combien d'humains qui vivent de
de l'océan qui vivent de la mer
idéal c'est des centaines de millions
voir 3 milliards de milliards ça dépend
ce qu'on appelle vivre de la mer est-ce
que c'est 100% de son de ses revenus
est-ce que c'est en partie est-ce que
c'est direct indirect mais en tout cas
on sait qu'on a 80 %, je crois de la
population mondiale qui vit dans la
borne côtière sur les quelques dizaines
de kilomètres au bord au bord des côtes
donc clairement on a l'humanité qui
dépend de l'océan pour le transport pour
l'alimentation pour
la régulation du climat etc donc
le nombre de gens qui dépendent vraiment
à 100% de de la pêche de la biodiversité
marine il y en a peu c'est certainement
quelques milliers centaines de milliers
il y a des populations par exemple à
Madagascar ou les habitants dépendent
exclusivement de la pêche pour leur
apport de protéines animales il y a rien
d'autre il y a que des poissons comme
protéines animales dans leur régime
alimentaire et donc c'est ces
populations là bien évidemment qu'on a
besoin de les protéger nous on n'a pas
besoin de pêcher pour s'alimenter je
reste vous parce que on a démarré ce
débat sur le ce traité signé à l'ONU qui
qui concerne les eaux internationales
on pourrait dire que c'est un bien
commun de l'humanité sauf que ce bien
commun il est exploité par combien de
pays et au bénéfice de qui quoi c'est
une vraie question c'est une question
d'ailleurs qui a été au centre des
débats sur sur ce traité là qui a aussi
été au centre de des derniers débats sur
sur le réchauffement climatique on a les
personnes qui souffrent qui sont pas les
premiers responsables du réchauffement
climatique pour le traiter sur la haute
mer c'est la même chose en fait on a
quelques pays voilà la France le Canada
des très grands pays développés qui vont
aller exploiter les ressources minières
les ressources génétiques ça c'était
vraiment un point crucial du traité sur
la haute mer et donc on a besoin aussi
de mettre en place des mécanismes de
compensation une enveloppe commune pour
que ça bénéficie à tout le monde puisque
il est impensable que ce soit BASF ou
une compagnie min dans le canadienne qui
engrangent des centaines de milliards
d'euros sur ces sur ces ressources
communes alors que à côté on a des pays
en Afrique ou en Asie en Amérique du Sud
qui crèvent on a des on a des familles
climatiques qui ont commencé Madagascar
on a d'autres pays qui arrivent on a les
îles du Pacifique qui disparaissent donc
bien évidemment qu'on a besoin d'avoir
un mécanisme de compensation là on a on
a mis en place ces cette possibilité là
l'Union européenne par exemple a annoncé
mettre sur la table 40 millions d'euros
40 millions d'euros c'est 25 fois moins
que le fond structurel européen à louer
à la pêche chaque année donc on est
quand même sur des encore des effets
d'annonce et maintenant il va falloir
que ce soit suivi dans les faits merci
beaucoup un dernier mot Jean-Louis
Étienne par exemple qui sont saisis du
Parlement de Madagascar ils ont comme
ressources le mouton et le calmar et
donc il protège ces zones là et donc ça
se pêche souvent la nuit avec des
bateaux éclairés et donc si vous faites
des images aériennes à ce moment-là vous
voyez donc la zone économique la
frontière de la zone économique est
protégée
parlez par les faux clans et tout autour
vous voyez tous ces bateaux qui sont à
la limite à la lisière de la frontière
autorisée en grande quantité beaucoup
viennent de l'Asie bien sûr et donc
c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à gérer
cette pêche intensive qui est compliquée
à gérer l'océan est tellement grand quoi
merci beaucoup c'était passionnant merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat on
va vous souhaiter évidemment bon vent
pour pour polar pod pour votre goélette
persévérance et voilà on suivra
évidemment ce projet passionnant de de
près merci à tous encore une fois merci
à vous de votre fidélité à ce sens
public je vous dis à demain vous pouvez
nous voir évidemment aussi sur le site
alors à toutes les émissions de la
chaîne évidemment sur la plateforme
public senna.fr et puis demain dans la
matinale Lauriane mancinio Hervé
Marseille le président du groupe Union
centriste au Sénat belle soirée à toutes
et à tous